ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا دكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان دكتور اهلا بكم معنا كيف
يمكن ان تقيم وضع المستشفيات بعد يعني
اقفال العديد من المستشفيات بسبب عدم
حصولها على اي امدادات طبيه وحتى الكادر
الطبيه يعني لا يستطيع الوصول اليها ماذا
يمكن ان تفيدنا بهذا الشان
السلام عليكم احييكم احيي الجميع الشعب
السوداني تحيه الصحه والعافيه
والرحمه والمغفره للذين فاضت ارواحهم الى
بارعها وحياكم الغطاء الصحي الذي مازال
يقدم الخدمات الصحيه
لمرضى السودان ولايه على وجه الخصوص في
هذه في ظل هذه الظروف بالغه التعويض الوضع
الصحي في السودان ما زال بخير وفي ولايه
الخرطوم على وجه الخصوص ما زال بخير انا
سمعت التصريح بتاعكم ده هو عاري عن الصحه
تماما
عندما تخرج عن الخدمه اكثر من يعني يقال
بانه 39 مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه
هي تعمل وثلاثه ثلاثون لا يعملون
الرسمي اي كلام عن وزاره الصحه غير غير
الجهه المسؤوله يعتبر كلام غير دقيق
طبعا عدد المستشفيات التي تقدم الخدمه
الخرطوم 133 مستشفى 53 مستشفى القطاع
العام 81 القطاع الخاص المستشفيات دي في
الوضع في وضع السلم
المواطنين يستغلون فقط 30% من مقدره
الاستيعابيه للعيان
الان المستشفيات خارج الخدمه من القطاع
العام 10 مستشفيات لانه في مرمى النيران
تم تفريغ العيانين لمستشفيات اكثر امانا
مستشفيات بديله مستشفيات القطاع الخاصه
التي خرجت
مستشفى الان اليوم خمسه مستشفيات عدد
الخدمه خدمه منها 15 ايضا في مرمى النار
تم تفريغ العيانين الى مستشفيات امنه
ومستشفيات السلاح السلاح الطبي
تاملت لكم ممرات امينه حتى قمتم باجلاء
هؤلاء المرضى الى مستشفيات اخرى استاذ
محمد
تقديم الخدمات
الكوادر الموجوده في
الخدمات الطارئه والخدمات شفه الطارئه
ترددات المسلسلات الان تساوي اثنين الى
اربعه في الوقت الطبيعي
تستقبل في المتوسط من يوم 15 وحتى تاريخ
اليوم فجر اليوم من 200 الى 400 حاله
يوميا هذا يساوي 2% من المقدره
الاستيعابيه للمستشفيات
دكتور هل يمكن ان تطلعنا اذا كانت هذه
المستشفيات لديها ما يكفي من المستلزمات
الطبيه هل الكادر الطبي قادر ان يصل الى
هذه المستشفيات الطبيه الان ما في اي
مستشفى طلبت اي معينات بتاعه مستهلكات
المستهلكات الموجوده فيها الان تكفي
التردد
البديهه من المسيفات اضيف الى ذلك عندنا
الامدادات الصحيه لام الفاتحه في منطقه
الخرطوم ودواء مؤسسه دواء الدائري وصندوق
الدواء الدائري في منطقه بحري الان
الوزاره عبر اسعافاتها تنقل الكوادر الحد
الادنى من الكوادر للمستشفيات العامله
الاكثر امانا الطرفيه والمستشفات المحليه
طب بالنسبه لسيارات الاسعاف دكتور محمد هل
تواصلتم مع الاطراف المتنازعه لتامين
مسارات امنه لهم حتى يستطيعوا التحرك
نعم تم التواصل الان الاسعافات تتحرك في
مناطقها
لحد تاريخ اللحظه ما احتجنا لانه نحرك
اسعاف يعبر الجسور كل المستيفات الان في
المسيفات المحليه بسبع ولايات تم اخلاء
منطقه الخرطوم اللي هي المنطقه الاكثر
ضررا بالاشتباكات من الكوادر الصحيه ومن
المرضى دكتور هل لديك اخر احصائيه عن عدد
الوفيات وعدد الاصابات نعم عدد الاصابات
من تاريخ صباح 15 وحتى فجر اليوم
1722 حاله اصابه
الوفيات 105 حاله وفاه موثقه
اما وفاء اثناء تقديم الخدمات الصحيه او
وفاء لتاكيد الوفاء من خارج من خارج
المستشفى
العسكريين انهم 15 حاله المصابين من
العسكريين الذين وردوا الى هزيمه التلقي
لعلاج 186 حاله
عدد العمليات الكبيره الهجريه عمليات
استخراج
الاعين الناريه من الراسه والصدر او البطن
او
الحوض او الكسور المركبه 318 عمليه منها
251 عمليه في القطاع العام 67 عمليه في
الغطاء الخاص وهنالك 31 حاله في العنايه
المكثفه 13 حاله في القطاع العام و18 حاله
في القطاع الخاص
التي
وصلت الى المشارح 50 جثمان وجميع الجسامين
تم تسليمهم الى
كنا بالامس تابعنا بعض الفيديوهات الجثث
ملقاه في الشارع هل تمكنت سيارات الاسعاف
ان تنقل هذه الجثث ام لا علم لديك بهذا
الامر بعد مناسباتنا عبر الغرفه المركزيه
مع الجهاز
الان طلع تعميم بانه قوات الشرطه
نزلت الى الشوارع
لاجلال جسامنا للمشارح
عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في
السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات